and speaking of things that also make
absolutely no sense whatsoever
new reports have revealed that ice
officials were instructed by the trump
administration
to wipe
their cell phones
before he left office
so prior to january 20th of 2021
we have ice officials it has now been
confirmed of course
that deleted
all of the data off of their phones
just like we saw with members of the
department of justice members of the
department of homeland security and of
course most famously
the united states secret service
everybody just wiped all their phones
deleted everything off it text messages
emails notes games
whatever it was
totally erased it all
and even if
just like the secret service claimed
right oh this was just routine we just
this is a thing we do cool totally
understand that
you're still required by law
to preserve the
data and that's the big part that i
think a lot of people don't quite
understand about this
it is not
routine
for the doj for the homeland security
for the secret service to just wipe
everything off the phone
and turn it back in and say all right
thank you bye i'll see you next time
no
the phones are taken
inventory is done
they are copied
and then
they are wiped
and this of course only applies to
agency issued phones which
most of these people do have agency
issued phones and they have it for that
specific reason so that the data is
saved so that there are records of the
things that they do the communications
that they have
so that they can make sure these
individuals are not sending it to people
who shouldn't be receiving it and in
case there's any malfeasance we can
point it out
due to the records on their devices
and now we know that ice
immigrations and customs enforcement
wiped their phones just like so many
other government agencies
under donald trump
i don't know
how much more of this
we can go through
how many more
cell phones were wiped
before trump left
how many other agencies how many other
officials were given these orders
to scrub it all to get rid of any
evidence get rid of any trace of
anything make sure nobody knows who we
were talking to and when we were talking
to them and what we were talking to them
about
that should terrify you
and every single person involved
needs to be investigated because like i
said it's illegal
to delete these records
they are required by law to back them up
and i'm not saying go find the i.t
department and arrest those guys
for wiping the devices
they probably didn't know that they
hadn't been backed up
whoever made the call whoever made the
decision
for all of these devices to be wiped at
whatever agency it is we're talking
about that day
those are the people that need to be
held accountable
and
maybe there's a couple honest folks in
there
maybe some of them backed up their own
data maybe they understood that i was
just following orders is not necessarily
a good excuse
for breaking the law so maybe
there are records somewhere
right even in the case of the secret
service and all their missing cell phone
data once the investigation was lost
they came back and magically said oh
wait wait we just found data on 10
devices look at that wow
suddenly it's crazy
we may be looking at a situation like
that
but only if we put the pressure on these
organizations and that pressure has to
either come from congress or it has to
come from the biden administration via
the department of justice
that's what has to happen
remains to be seen though right
i guess we have to wait